- All right, everybody.
We've reached the end of the hour,
but before we go, I have one
last amazing story to share.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding and cheering)
So Amazon might have figured out how
to deliver books the fastest,
but they've got nothing on a bookstore
in Philly who delivers books on horseback.
It's amazing and that's how
I wanna receive my books
from now on.
The even cooler thing
is the story is called
Harriett's Bookshop named
after abolitionist Harriet Tubman.
And their mission is to
actually honor the legacy
of black Americans.
Here to tell us more is the
owner of Harriett's Bookshop.
So say hi to Janine who usually watches
on NBC10 Philadelphia at 2.
So Janine, so horseback delivery is just
like one way that your
store is different right?
- Right, right.
Our store does a lot of
things very differently.
So what you see when
we're delivering books
by horseback is a part of our mission
to celebrate Harriet Tubman,
to celebrate women
authors and women artists
and women activists.
And what happened was the
Fletcher Street Riding Club
came together and they were like,
"How can we support you?"
Right, so our bookshop had
only been open for six weeks,
six weeks before the pandemic hit.
- Oh wow.
- And so all many, many
communities have come together
to support us which I think is beautiful.
And what we did was we said,
"Okay, we're gonna jump on horseback
"and we're gonna keep on reading.
"We're gonna keep children
excited about books."
And that's what we've been
doing as much as we can.
- What a cool, like
innovative way as well.
That's so cool.
- And yeah, so it's been
a way that we can like,
again, keep it fresh keep it funky,
keep it exciting for folks
- And personalize it, yeah.
- And, and now the Bookshop is a whole
nother bookshop again.
Right, so we, we had artists come together
and when you walk in, you're
literally inside of a book.
So there's illustrations on
every wall, on the floors, yeah.
- Love that, what a clever
way to get people back
in stores and buying
like, like reading books.
I like having something
tangible still in my hand.
- Absolutely.
- I can't, I've tried so hard.
I can't do like the reader thing.
I can't do it.
I like the smell of a book.
I like going into a bookstore.
I love all of it.
So where did your love
of reading come from?
- So many places but one
my mother was getting,
who was a librarian.
She was getting her master's degree when
I was a little girl.
And as she was doing that,
she started to go blind.
And so what happened was my mother,
very tenacious woman,
decided to keep on going
to school and she would have
us read her books to her.
So that's what we did.
We read to her, we wrote with her,
for her and she continue
until she got that degree.
And I think that watching
books as a community effort
in our household became like
a part of my whole life.
- What a special
connection that y'all have.
What a beautiful thing.
- Thank you, thank you.
- And just to keep persevering and keep
and not let that get in your way.
- Absolutely.
- Wow.
Well, thank you so much.
I love,
you have a powerful story.
- Thank you.
- I love this book store.
Everybody go visit.
I'm liking your post, right now.
(audience applauding and cheering)
And that's not all.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to honor ultimate
overachievers just like you ma'am,
so they are going to
be writing you a check
for $1,000 just to help out.
- (laughing) Thank you.
- Thank you so much.
And you look so beautiful and cool.
I'm so jealous right now of this outfit.